[Music]
you
hello friends welcome back to this
second section on language in the first
section of language we saw what is
language we saw how it differentiates
from communication and we saw several
parts of language how it is made up of
what is a syntax what is for name what
is a morpheme and then what is cement
takes what is pragmatics so basically
that comprises of order languages and
then at the end of it grammar so
basically what language is what it is
composed of how these things the rules
of grammar really work into language and
so on and so forth now in this section
will focus on to something called
understanding comprehension of language
and the production of language so first
section was describing things about the
nature of language and the second
section is about producing language and
understanding comprehending language so
basically let's start this session and
try and understand how language is
comprehended how language is understood
or how language is produced now language
like any other information which is
being transferred from one person to
another is basically first taken in as a
raw input and its transformed so the
basic components of language are first
perceived through a language processing
unit in the brain and then it is the raw
materials or the raw parts of the
language are then processed by this
language processing unit to form
meaningful representations where these
representations then mean something or
has some semantic value now the steps
which are followed in taking the raw
language input and then processing it so
that a meaningful representation as
meaningful representation is created
what are the steps into it let's look
into those so the question is how does
speech perception happen how do you
perceive speech now as opposed to
perception of words which we do one word
at a time
one by one so how does word conception
happen or perception of letters and
numbers happen so basically what we do
is we do some kind of fixation and we do
some kind of jumps and these fixation
and jumps happen from the first word to
the first letter of the word to the last
letter of the word then there is a gap
and within that gap the meaning of the
word is is evaluated and then we go to
the next word and similarly in terms of
speech perception since perception of
words happen this way in individual
materials happens in the way that I just
described so it's basically believed
that speech perception should also
follow something like this and the
simplest way to look at house pieces
perception would happen is to be like
text perception that is one sound at a
time should be perceived and the pauses
between the spoken word to spoken words
should be used to identify the meaning
of the words this is how our general
knowledge should be because text
perception basically takes place I send
you it takes place in terms of a word my
word perception so the first letter of
the word and last letter of the word is
basically looked into this is called
jumping or fixations which the eye - and
based on that there is a gap and if
there is no gap then perception of
letters become difficult but this gap
between letters actually help the brain
to interpret the meaning of the word and
so this goes on and this is how the
meaning is generated so in speech
perception also it should be we assume
that you should be similar that a word
by word is perceived each word that
somebody is speaking now when I am
speaking to you how the perception
should work in this way that you should
be
perceiving each word and the gap in my
speaking the time gap between two words
when I speak that should be utilized for
making meaning out of it that's how we
believe it is but that's not how
actually it really works so milna 1990
he described two problems with such a
theory which says that word by word
perception happens and meaning is
generated from those kind of words and
what is these two problems first Miller
he found out that speech was continuous
in nature the nature of speech was
continuous and so how does it happen for
example refer to the spectrogram so I
what I'll show you I'll show you
spectrogram so what is the spectrogram
actually this is an output of speech so
once once you produce speech the there
is a air pressure so just in front of
the mouth so one once the words come out
of your mouth a certain air pressure is
created and this air pressure is
measured through a instrument and it is
displayed in through a spectrograph
through a CRT tube or a spectrograph and
that's how what is a basically a
spectrogram is so the amount of pressure
which is generated when you speak
certain words against when you speak
nothing is presented on an XY coordinate
in terms of voltages in in in in terms
of sounds n in terms of sound in Hertz
and on the time axis so that's how a
spectrogram really works so effective
Graham is basically these pressures that
I omit when speaking a word and the
graph of it which is in terms of sounds
in the produce in terms of Hertz and the
width through a particular time so I'm
just going to show you a spectrogram of
the word that I am written down here so
they are buying some bread let's look at
this and if we find all this stops or
obvious gaps in the spectrogram it would
mean that speech is not continuous and
so each word after each word there is a
gap so let's look into it so
spectrograms this is a spectrogram as
you can look at and so when you look at
the spectrogram it is one contained
the omission of an continuous graph
which is out there so on this axis we
have the time and on this axis we have
the measurement of sound in terms of
Hertz it's so air pressure basically in
terms of Hertz and so what is the result
of this the result of this is that
spectrograms indicate it rapidly there
are pauses around each sound so once the
sound is produced there are no pauses
between them and rather different sounds
from the same words blend into each
other so what happens is when I say they
are brining the bread what really
happens is the end of the and the
beginning of our are blended together
and so there is no graph and that is
what Milner pointed out he said that
speech is continuous so assuming that
speech is like perception of text is not
correct one reason being that you
discuss I just showed you that this
sentence they are buying some bread in
terms of a spectrogram how it will look
like and we see that the word endings
they sort of merge into each other and
so there are very few chances or there
are no chances for gaps between them
which which negates the idea that people
get timed to between spoken language to
make meaning order now the second
problem which Miller listed is the fact
that a single phoneme when if it is
changed into a spoken text the context
changes for example if I remove if a toe
a doe and auto can be made these words
can be made by replacing the TD no.4
name so a single phoneme have taken out
or if it is replaced or if it is
misheard in certain way what would
happen is the word would itself change
and so one single phone a one single
speech sound and phoneme is a very basic
idea so one thing simple problem with
hearing this one on would actually lead
to the interpretation or would actually
lead to different interpretation
altogether and so what I have here is
that this same for you so you have this
is for toe this is for Doh and this is
for auto and
as you can see here that this is the
time axis in terms of time as you see
it's 200 400 millisecond and this is the
pressure air pressure so in terms of
sound pressure in terms of Hertz or
cycles per second and so what you see is
that the same kind of spectrograph you
can see for both no.2 and auto but only
the beginning changes so replacing a
phoneme for example T replaced by a D or
o the beginning of this changes but more
or less it is the same right and so
that's what it is one of fun for phoneme
changes the whole idea of the word or
whole meaning of the word changes no
these are the two facts why it the Y
sound perception cannot be similar to
speech perception now another problem
which is to be noted is that men and
women they speak in different
frequencies different accents and across
different contexts they people speak in
different ways so it's not about gender
it's not about how women and men speak
together it is also dependent on the
kind of frequency so some people speak
very softly some people speak a little
bit loud the kind of accents that people
use so it could be a raw accent it could
be a toned up accent or any reason at
different situations for examples in a
lecture you could be whispering in some
other fora when you're lecturing it
could be a monotonous tone and so on and
so forth so across context across
different different situations people
both men and women use different kind of
you know speaking or speak differently
and so this could be another problem
which could lead to the fabulous speech
perception is not like text perception
so then if it is not like text
perception how is speech perceived then
what is the way in which pitch
perception happen and the answer to this
is that speech perception is generally
categorical in nature and that's what it
is the answer is that we come specially
a cube with pursed
systems which perceives speech in an
efficient way in a very efficient way
and that is called categorical
processing so what happens here is that
certain categories are automatically
made and so when we speak the speech is
automatically without awareness pushed
into these categories and at how we
actually go ahead and process speech we
pay attention to certain acoustic
properties of the speech and ignore
certain others so based on the caustic
properties we can tell whether a person
is male or female
remember experiments from the attention
section where we saw that from the
unshadowed ear people were able to tell
things like the tone of wise and the
gender of the person who's speaking and
so these things are automatically
attention is paid onto it automatically
and so people were able to tell from the
Nanshan down here also so basically in
categorical processing what really
happens is there are certain categories
and these within these categories when
you when a person is speaking
automatically we perceive or we force
the spoken speech into these fixed
categories and this happens without
awareness we are not really aware of the
fact that we are doing it so we are not
perceiving it in a continuous manner we
are not perceiving it in the breakdown
manner but what we do is certain
categories arise so what is a noun what
is the work kind of categories are
different different categories or what
could be the constraint category and so
we look into speech or with the hear
speech and we take parts of speech and
they we then go ahead and then push it
these parts into different different
categories out there and that happens
without of any kind of awareness we are
the kind of explicity into it so
perception of speech is also affected by
something called visual cues and these
are known as context effect so certain
kind of visual cues in the environment
they also affect kind of perception of
speech that we do know the an experiment
was done to show that these different
things that context affects perception
of speech and so Warren what it did was
he presented a statement like this to
people now the statement was the state
governess meant with their respective it
should actually be legislators right and
so that is what it is about where the
word ledge is the word s would the
fundamental come he produced a coughing
sound so the statement transcends the
state government met with their
respective legislatures concerning in
the covering convening in the capital
city so this is what the basic sentence
was and so what he did was in the world
legislature where this phoneme would be
a cough sound was produced a light cough
salsa produced and it was amazingly
people were not able to identify the
cuff sound only one out of twenty people
actually they reported hearing the cuff
sound nineteen people didn't didn't
actually report the cough sound and they
could hear the word legislature very
nicely nicely and the honam s here
legislature so funny mess and this
basically is what is called the phoneme
restoration effect so in which one
hundred twenty so that is what it is so
this sentence of presented and 120 milli
second portion was replaced the this was
120 milli second portion where a phoneme
was there and a cuffing sound was
induced so one after twenty percent
listening to this actually found out
that there was a missing phoneme and
most of the 19 people restored this one
him and that is called the phoneme
distortion effect and that demonstrates
that the the percept the perception that
we actually do is a categorical in
nature so we don't look for look through
word to words we actually force
implicitly or without awareness we force
part of sentences into preformed
categories and that is our perception of
speech really happens so the answer to
this or the result of this experiment
were that people were capable of using a
great deal of information to predict
what the correct sound of the missing
segment was and as I said that people
were able to restore this phone him they
didn't notice this break which was there
and because they were doing categorical
processing they were not even aware of
it that this
been replaced by a cough sound now
Warren Warren in 70 they demonstrated
this by presenting people with one of
the four sentences so they're people
represented people with these four
sentences now each one was the same
recording with the exception of the
final word has been spliced off and each
contained a missing segment as indicated
in the Asterix on so basically what
Warren did Lauren wanted first to find
out whether people are able to restore
this one him or not or perform this
phoneme restore restoration which
basically means that are people capable
of implicitly filling up gaps into
spoken speech to demonstrate that what
Warren Wan did was he presented four
different sentences to people with one
phoning being spliced off and what he
wanted to see was whether people
restored these phonemes or not so there
were four sentences present to people
with a missing segment and each of this
in each of this the missing segment is
the key to making meaning of the
sentence so what were the sentences the
first sentences was it was found that
eel was on the exel the second was it
was found that star eel was on the shoe
and so this star which you see here is
basically the missing phone him here and
so I'm pretty sure by now you would have
come to know the answer for all of these
and so this is what was replacing in in
worst case this eel was an Lda to an
excel in the second case this eel was
related to a shoe in the third case it
was related to an orange and the fourth
case it was related to a table now take
a second and tell me what the eel should
actually be and I'm pretty sure that you
would have come up with an answer so in
the first case when the neck seal was
presented the context help people to
replenish back or to fit in the right
phoneme and so people perceived really
there but in in the second case where it
was the shoe people didn't say wheel but
people perceive the EE L the the the
part where the phoneme was placed off as
heel not wheel the wheel was for axle
because the axle is the context and so
wheel was replaced in if shoe is the
context then what was replaced was heel
but in the third case when
orange was the context when orange was
what was being referred to the missing
portion became peel whereas in the
fourth case when table was what was the
context or what was the whole sentence
was referring to
it was meal correct and that's what it
is and so depending on the sentence
participants reported hearing wheel heel
peel and meal so basically they restored
this morning's of WH the H H in heel the
P in peel and the M in meal this kind of
thing is that which basically again
proves the hypothesis that people
perceive speech sound automatically and
implicitly and how they do it they do it
through something called categorical
processing right as a speech perception
is basically not like text perception
people don't wait over speech segments
and the gap between CC segments are not
utilized for making meaning rather the
perception happen in the categorical
automatic manner
now with the perception of speech or
speech itself there are certain errors
which are there when we produce speech
also so certain areas can also arise
when production of speech happens so so
beside perceiving speech from others we
also produce speech and for others to
comprehend the and process the speech
fear so it's not only always listening
we all sometimes also talk so we produce
speech and so this is called speech
production now speech production can
need to switch production itself can
lead to certain kind of errors which are
called speech errors interactions in
which the speaker intends to say quite
clearly where the speaker makes some
solutions substitutions or reorders the
stimulus in a certain way so speech
errors then are certain substitutions
are certain reordering of the statement
which makes the sentence not legible and
so these are happening this happens
because we do some kind of a reordering
in sentence productions or we do some
kind of a substitution in sentence
production and those are called speech
errors for example Mary keeps the food
in her West now when we say whisk
actually this is wrong and so what are
happening so you would see these kind of
things happening in smaller children's
and so what have happened here obviously
you can see is the desk the DS replaced
by the phone in V and so what has
happened is Mary keeps wood in her desk
so instead of the desk the production
itself it becomes reversed and it
happens to most of us we do these kind
of problems another is another sentence
which shows this kind of speech
production error is this one where we
sometimes make this kind of errors also
where what we have done is it's exchange
of words sometimes we replace phonemes
are sometimes the exchanged words also
so look at the sentence we sit around
the song and sing fire and so it happens
to most of us you'll realize that people
who can speak English they can have
these kind of errors in to it and so
here what has happened is the song is
replaced by fire so the actual sentence
should be we sit around the fire and
sing songs and so out of some
substitution in speech production what
has happened his fire goes to the end of
the sentence song comes to the middle of
the sentence and our sentence becomes we
sit around the song and sing fires which
has which is syntactically correct it is
semantically correct but makes no
meaning at any indian aid so in terms of
pragmatics make no meanings so in terms
of grammar rules is perfectly correct
but it has no meaning and so this is an
error of speech production and this
error arises because we substitute
certain words for certain other words
similarly Gerrit 1990 88 while studying
such these errors found that the word
substitution has two broad categories of
errors so this substitution of words
this exchange of words can then also be
divided into two different classes two
huge classes out there and what are
these classes one of what substitution
can error have never solution error can
happen in terms of meaning relations so
in terms of meaning relations in the
sense that I can substitute a word by
another word which is equivalent to the
meaning of the first word
so here replacing finger
or walk with a run is what meaning
relations are there so finger and toe
are more or less like similar in
meanings of what finger does is what a
toe would does and walk and run are more
or less same in meaning similar in
meaning exactly not the same but then
similar meaning and so people could
actually do this kind of word
substitution error and these word
solution substitution errors are meaning
related errors or people can go ahead
and form form relation errors so form
relations errors are generally very
fewer it is very few that you see these
kind of errors and so what you do here
is instead of a guest you would say good
so the guest has come the goat has come
right or mushroom is replaced by
mustache so let's go to the feeling and
pick up fresh mustache instead of the
mushroom so form relation errors can
also exist and so Garrett says that
these are two kinds of speech errors or
speech related errors that can exist and
so these speech related errors can also
create or are also categorized into form
relations and meaning relations okay so
this is up till now we have seen that in
the production of speech also so not
only that writing language or written
language has some kind of errors while
producing speech also we create a number
of errors and so what we saw up till now
is how speech is produced and this
production of categorical speech the
production of speech itself which has
which is categorical in nature this can
also lead to certain kind of errors
which the producer of the speech is
making and which confuses the listener
and so he would be hearing something
else right and so the question now is
how do we comprehend the sentence right
so when somebody writes a sentence how
do we go ahead and read this sentence so
how do people understand and recover
their meaning from sentences so given
the fact that a certain sentence is
written in fact in front of you how do
you make meaning from such a sentence
the answer to this lies to the fact that
people pay attention to syntactic
constraints however they do do not
process sentence clause by clause so
what people generally do is that they
look at a sentence and they look at
parts of the sentence or they look at
the syntactic constraint of a sentence
right but then they do not process the
sentence Clause by Clause so what really
did they do they actually look at a
sentence look at the Sun send the
constituent of a sentence make a gist
out of it and that is how they process a
sentence they actually don't read the
sentence cross by clause and that is the
way in which people go ahead and process
sentences so what after reading a
sentence what people do is they discard
most of the words in the sentence and
just keep the meaning the central
representation or the central meaning in
terms of a gist representation so
comprehending a sentence involves
dissolving it's possible ambiguities so
in sentence comprehension also certain
kind of errors can occur and so it has
been found that people are very good in
resolving ambiguities if a sentence and
we saw that in the first section also
that even if the sentence is a certain
problem people they are able to resolve
the ambiguity for example the first
sentence that we looked at the very
yellow dog chase something something we
saw that people are able to people all
they don't know the descriptive rules of
grammar of how to correct the sentence
but they know the prescriptive rules and
they know how to correct this so in
terms of sentence comprehension also
people are very good in resolving these
ambiguities now in the interesting thing
here is that we normally don't notice
ambiguities and only rarely we come to
notice them when do we know ambiguities
only when certain kind of sentences
arise or a certain kind of certain parts
of the sentence have some confusions in
to us now look at this sentence the
sentence says the horserace past the
bond fell now if you look into the
sentence what happens is initially the
sentence is alright the horserace past
the bank till the point that you come to
fell and fell is ambiguous and these
kind of sentences are called garden path
sentence so you it leads you to a
certain direction of meaning but then
the last word creates a
problem and so what is the problem so
how do we go ahead and solve this what
is the this is obviously an ambiguity so
how do you solve this one way to solve
it is the horse weight raced past and
put a comma here the bond fell two parts
of the sentence two sentences to look at
na makes meaning or the horse raced past
the bond fell can be broken not into
this two constants and so till the point
of time that you're reading the horse is
past the bond it is okay but a fell the
word fell itself is a problem and so
here is the problem so you can solve it
by this way and this type of sentences
actually lead to ambiguities or look at
this now this sentence is the cotton
shirts are made from comes from Arizona
not from from the beginning of the
sentence if you read there is a but the
pertinent meaning that you see to it but
at a point a certain point certain water
arises which creates confusion for
example the cotton shirts are made from
comes from Arizona now there is a
problem here the cotton shirts are made
from expects certain input as some form
of it alright what fine form of cotton I
am destroying that kind of cotton
qualifying the cotton example so
simplifying this sentence so basically
if you want to make meaning of the
sentence and so the here is where so we
will decide the cotton shirts are made
from made from comes from Arizona is
where the problem really comes in and so
you want to solve this sentence the
ambiguity ambiguity is this part of the
sentence I just want to solve the
ambiguity what we really do is cotton
shirts the if we put a comma here the
cotton shirts are made from comes from
Arizona then the sentence losses is an
ambiguity and becomes a more meaningful
sentence but reading from from on words
in to say in this way creates an
ambiguity and so this kind of sentences
creates ambiguity but with normal
ambiguity because what happens is the
people have already started reading the
sentence and so it has made people
started thinking in a particular
direction but then from the from on
words or from the ban on words the next
word which appears creates
so this kind of sentences make people
that assume confusions or make people
think about confusions and they need to
then solve the ambiguity so these
sentences are then called garden path
sentences the reason being that it
starts making you think in a certain way
and then at some point of the sentence
it pushes you into a different movie
right so results from several studies
they suggest that when we process
ambiguous sentences all the meaning of
the sentences are temporarily available
so when we are looking at these kind of
ambiguous sentences and M because
sentences which has multiple meaning and
the results from several experiments
suggest that all meanings of the
sentences are available for example if
there is a sentence saying that this
room means full of bugs
now both the meaning of the bugs the
bugs as in terms of cockroaches or pets
or bugs in terms of listening devices
are available to us depending on the
context we then decide after three
phoneme lengths which word meaning will
be accurate and so results from several
studies basically suggest that so
basically what it suggests is that when
we are reading an ambiguous sentence all
the meaning of the ambiguous word the
word which is creating ambiguity are
temporarily available through an
automatic bottom-up process so while
reading a sentence every meaning
remember the sentence where we use Bank
in two different ways in in terms of
financial institutions and in terms of
riverfront now both the meaning are
available if a sentence is this Bank is
creating confusion in a sentence both
the meanings would be available at the
time of processing the sentence now
quanta fix effects do not immediately
restrict the listener to most
appropriate reading of the word
so basically when we are reading a
sentence the various sentence is created
the context in which a sentence is
created it does not stop the reader from
interpreting all the meanings of the
ambiguous word right instead for a short
period all meanings are accessible to
them now three syllables after the
presentation of the ambiguous word only
one meaning remains active so what
happens is the context doesn't decide
what is the meaning of ambiguous word of
the ambiguous word which is created in
the word which is creating ambiguity in
ambiguous sentences what really happens
is three syllables after the processing
of the ambiguous word all meanings are
available only after these three
syllables has elapsed the exact meaning
or the meaning which befits the context
then remains and all other meanings are
discarded and so this such as has been
done on several kind of sentences and so
since this we are not dealing in detail
in language so I'm not bringing in those
examples which will show you how these
experiments are done and how it was
basically found out but this is the
result of it so three syllables after
the presentation of the ambiguous word
only one meaning remains active which is
the meaning which is more up most
appropriate to those contexts suggesting
that people resolve sentence ambiguity
fairly quickly so no matter how
ambiguous the sentences people are able
to resolve these ambiguities and how do
they do this resolving of ambiguity the
fact is we read the sentence to the
point they come to the fact that the
word which is creating ambiguity and
when they are reading the word this is
creating ambiguity context is the word
the context of the sentence doesn't help
them till three four names or three
syllables after the presentation of the
word all meanings are accessible but
only after three syllable presentations
which is a very very brief time only
after that the appropriate meaning or
the necessary meaning or the most
optimal meaning which befits that
sentence
it remains and all of the meaning goes
away and certain experiments are done to
create that and so what does it actually
tell you it tells you that people are
able to read up and because sentence is
very fast and resolve ambiguity very
fast right so although all meanings are
available but then people are very good
in resolving ambiguities although I mean
they may not know the grammar they may
not know what is wrong with a sentence
but they may that they can correct the
sentence so they have this feeling they
have this implicit feeling that is that
is what we saw in the first lecture they
said they have this
idea of what is wrong but they may not
know the grammar of where it is wrong
okay so up till now we have looked at
speech perception and sentence
comprehension very good let's now look
at what is the comprehension of a text
message or how text messages are
comprehended now for understanding how
people process takes messages first we
need to know how people actually need so
what is the way in which people read and
just in carpenter 1987 use something
called an eye tracker to monitor the eye
fixations for written text so what they
did was they use something called an eye
tracker SOI tracker actually tracks the
movement of the eyeball as it move
across written words and so from that
they had some idea of how people
actually me now results indicate that
reading consists of a series of
fixations and jump across text with
average fixation and jumping 250 and and
10 to 20 20 to power minus 3 second the
basically 250
to 10 to 20 20 millisecond kind of a
timeframe so basically then what they
found out from the study is that people
just don't read text the way is with
what happens is the eyeball tracking
experiment suggests that people jump
from word to word and they then have
fixations so when they're looking at a
word they look at the first word they
fixated they looked at the last letter
of the word they stopped there for some
time make meaning out of it
jump to the next first next letter or
next word the first letter the next word
last letter of the next word look at the
context find meaning next makes the
jumps and make another jump into it and
so this kind of jumping and fixations
how text is Percy now just in carpenters
model assume that as soon as readers
found encounter a new word they try to
interpret it and assign it a rule and
this is called the immediate immediacy
assumption so in takes passages what
just in carpenter says is that when we
are reading something in these fixation
happens between the first letter and the
last letter of the word
and then we wait there for certain time
the
is called a fixation time and then we
jump to the next word which is there now
during this period when we make this
jump this fixation and jump during that
period we immediately encounter when we
encounter that what immediately gather
the meaning of the word and that is
called the immediacy assumption so as
soon as we get a new word we try to
interpret what the word is the author
also formulated something called the
imine hypothesis and through water is it
which holds that interpretation of each
word occurs during the time it is
fixated so basically what happens is
when reading a text there are certain
jumps in the eye actually does and so if
you are reading at words like w RDS and
like these are the two things that we
are looking now I will first fixate here
stay here then look at the last word d s
then there is a context to it since it
is the language context in some words
are related to context so this we are
teaching this I'm teaching this in in a
lecture on language and so the context
is there and so this w word starting
with w ending with s or ending with D
would be a word that is how the
immediacy of immediacy assumption is and
so immediately that is what it is and
the imine hypothesis is that as the
fixation happens and I have before the
jump
this word is interpreted this word is
matched with a segment or matched with a
representation into the brain and a
meaning is extracted out of it and so
these are what it is immediacy says that
an interpretation is as is done as soon
as the fixation happens and a rule is
assigned to it and the imine hypothesis
says that meaning is also extracted at
the same point of fact so it is not only
the role assigning to new word what is
the role of that new word whether it is
a word whether it is a noun whether it
is a pronoun what kind what form it is
doing a sentence or what is the role
that is playing in a sentence that is
called the immediacy assumption the
i-mine hypothesis is that the meaning is
also extracted as that very time it's a
fixation time so fixation tells you what
each word means what is the role it has
in the sentence and what in hand and how
to interpret this there's this role in
the imine I possess it says that also
the meaning of the word is extracted at
point RAM and that is how we did so
these through these fixations and jumps
across words to words
is how we actually read and that is how
comprehension of text messages happen
now justin carpenter they argued that a
number of variables influenced fix a
influences fixation duration so the time
number the amount of time that the eye
fixates on to a particular word is
influenced by a number of variables and
so what are these variables for example
word length the bigger the word length
the more the fixation has to be right
also what frequency how frequently you
see even this word so words like apricot
words like hello where are was which
people don't encounter in everyday life
they require longer fixations then word
like cat dog hand food that kind of
words which are more common the flood
frequency the usage of these words are
more common and syntactically and
semantically ambiguous word so if words
are syntactically and semantically
ambiguous for example bank two meanings
of bank or bugs - meaning of the word
bugs or multiple meaning of the word bug
or the position of the word is such that
it can also be an injective and it also
be a noun that can happen so the word
could qualify it could cruel mean too
many things into it in those cases the
fixations are long or the fixations are
a larger duration and the jumps are then
quicker not quicker it's takes more time
to jump and the more the longer fixation
because that determines how much time
you have to spend into it why because
then you have to first if we have words
which are ambiguous we have to first
assign a role to it because that tool
will tell you what this word means and
what this word how this what is driving
the sentence right and so basically that
so longer the word the more complex the
word lesser the frequency more the
fixation period siltation keenan 73 they
found out the semantic factors influence
the reading task there are certain
semantic factors which also go ahead and
influence text comprehension or reading
tasks they showed that two sentences of
equal length might be diff
differentially difficult to process and
so they said that the cementing the
meaning how much meaning a sentence
carries how much ideas that the sentence
carries that will also decide how easily
a sentence can be read so those
sentences which has a number of ideas on
to them they will be difficult to
understand they will take more time to
comprehend or comprehension of sentences
which have multiple ideas embedded into
them will take more time than sentences
which have simple ideas and so they
presented something like this so the
word is Romulus the word is Romulus the
legendary founder of Rome took the woman
off of the Sabine by force and so there
are two or three ideas into it and so
you look into Romulus woman and by force
are three ideas and then you have Sabine
is a woman there these are two other
things and so the number of ideas are
limited here are three ideas and so it
takes some time to process in comparison
to that if you look into it it is the
same length the second sentence is also
the same length but here the number of
ideas are more and so it takes more time
to process and what is the sentence
Cleopatra's downfall lay in a foolish
trust in the fickle political figure or
the Roman world and so if you look into
it there are multiple ideas into it or
multiple segments into it now because of
what because of trust of Cleopatra
Cleopatra fell down and within that
within the trust
what kind of trust there is a foolish
trust there is a fickle trust and there
is the part of the world so that is
related to the Cleopatra and figure in
in one idea and Cleopatra falling down
is the other idea so trusting of paper
ties one idea and falling down of
Cleopatra is another idea and within
that there are certain systems which are
there and if we look into it it has
multiple ideas right and so if it has
multiple ideas it will take more time to
process and so the more meaning more
ideas that have the more meaning is to
be interpreted the more meaning of
sentence has the more time it will take
to be interpreted and the more fixations
are required into it and the longer
duration of comprehension for such words
now another factor which influences the
processing of text has to do with
relationship among sentences what
sentences or how sentences are related
to each other so the more the sentences
are related to each other the larger the
relationship or if those two sentences
are not related to each other then it
will take more time to be process now
halav and and clark 1974 describes
something called a given new strategy
and what is this given new strategy
they say that whereby listeners are
listeners and readers divide sentences
into two parts the given part and the
new part so when they are listening into
a sentence when people who listen to a
sentence they are listening in to us and
hence they immediately divide the
sentence into two parts one is the given
part the other is the new part now the
given part of our sentence contains
information that is familiar from the
context of the preceding information or
the background information so when you
are listening to a sentence what you
tend to do is break this intends into
its two part first part is the given
part the given part has all the
informations on given partners all the
inputs from preceding context are from
where the borrower over effect from
previous sentences and people are
familiar with it the new part contains
unfamiliar information new part of the
sentence they can contain unfamiliar
information so listeners first search
memory for information current
corresponding to the given information
and update memory by incorporating the
new information offer as an elaboration
the given part so basically then let's
look at a sentence and then see how does
this thing really work so basically what
I'm doing is I'm creating two sentences
and with a given part of a new part so
if I write this sentence we got some
beer out of the car this is the first
part and the second part is the beer was
Wow so sentence number one sentence
number two right this is the given part
and this is the new part
similarly we checked
the picnic supplies and then again the
same this is the given part and the beer
was warm now in which case do you think
people will take more time to comprehend
yes you are right in the first case
people will take lesser time to
comprehend this sentence the reason
being that in the given sentence in the
given part of the sentence the mention
of beer is there and so it makes a
relation with this sentence and so the
comprehension is easy so make basically
they got from where are the currents so
they were wrong it's easy to interpret
but in this case the mention of beer is
not there in the first sentence and so
you don't know how the new part connects
to the old part and so then first you
have to make the assumption that beer is
part of the picnic supplies first you
have to make this supposition assumption
only then you can comprehend this
sentence in this case it is easy because
previa contexts provide you that idea
and so if this is a given new sentence
people will take lesser time to verify
this one then this one because the first
part of the sentence contains the
referral to the new part right so this
is basically what they say so in a given
new strategy the more different the
given and new parts are the more
difficult comprehension turns out to be
now when they brew and and Gustafson in
1990 they offered three conclusions from
research on reading text first the
mental representation is a construction
by the reader
which differs from and goes beyond the
information of the text itself when you
read something and that is why I always
advise my students to read books what
happens is when you read something you
make a new world out of it a new
construction you go beyond the book and
imagine things which is not written even
in the text and so people own this
mental imagery and so in the in the last
chapter and mental magic we saw that
people have this mental imagery make
these mental representations it may
so once you read up texts people make
certain
imaginaries or certain texts or certain
kind of formats which are personal to
them and so they go beyond the what is
written in the world and that becomes
personal to us and so these personal
things this these personal influences
representations that we make or text
help us in understanding something so
when people read something they create a
mental representation which is personal
to them and it is beyond what is written
on to the text the second is the
representation is coherent when we read
text the representations have to be
coherent in the sense that it is linked
in ways right so one part of the
sentence text should always be related
to the second pattern that is coherency
is there so even if we read elect if you
are reading a novel we read the back
part first in the front part in the
middle of the novel we still make this
coherency the fill up gaps is there in
this coherency is always maintained and
the third is this readers attentional
resources are limited we cannot be very
ambiguous in writing sentences if we
write very very ambiguous sentences the
actions our attention span of the
resources is limited text comprehension
will be flawed so when writing a text
for comprehending we should be assured
of the fact that first whatever we are
writing people are there people will
misinterpret it or people will create
their own construction sort of it so it
should be very limited it should be
should be written in a way that you
should give the chance for lesser
representation varied representation
also the representation that we form the
writing that we do should be coherent it
should not be all over the place having
all kind of meanings into it and third
that it should be written very strictly
in ways that respect people's attention
'el resources which basically means that
the idea should be clearly spread out if
it is not then people's attention
resources are very limited and so you
keep on jumping from one's meaning to
others to write them so this is how next
text comprehension happens now let's
look at an interesting fact which is
stories how do people comprehend stories
we have looked at how people comprehend
text now let's look at how people
comprehend stories so what is the way in
which people actually read stories and
so forth reading story it has been found
that there is something called story
grammars Sasori gammas are described as
the way in which people comprehend large
integrated pieces of text using script
schemas and grammar of the language so
while reading a story while reading a
novel while eating some kind of artwork
or fiction or nonfiction when reading
any kind of large text which they need
to comprehend they use certain kind of
dramas which is different from the kind
of grammar that we saw in the first part
of this lecture what is it then so what
our story grammars these are similar to
scripts in that both have variables or
slots data filled in differentially by
different stories
so basically story grammar is kind of a
script right it's kind of a block and so
what this block does is it this block
says that each story should have certain
fixed factors into it right so what
story Lama suggests is that people
expect certain kind of fixed factors so
for example when you are looking at a
story he story should have a protagonist
the person who's the one who's acting
the main component of the story or the
main person of the story they should
have a setting where the story is
setting from where it is coming from
where it is based on a plot or what
really happens in the story what is the
baseline of the story backgrounder story
conflicts and resolutions then if you
are writing a story there has to be some
kind of a conflict and then the
storyteller resolve this conflict and
all these are expectations that people
have and these are called story grammars
so every story should have things like
this these type of grandmas on to it now
story grammars are stimulated to
syntactic grammars in that they help us
identify the units of each role plays in
the story so basically like what drama
does for us what syntax does for us
because syntax tell you in a sentence
what is the subject what is the object
in what is the verb and what role each
object is playing in a sentence and that
helps you into making a legal sentence
similarly story grammars actually tell
you the main constituents of the story
what is the protagonist who is the
protagonist what is the plot what is the
setting what is the tone what are the
conflicts which are there what are the
resolutions so that you come to
in in one brief look into it what the
story is about or what the story is
going to tell you right and so these
these are fixed factors it is screwy
Gramma's are like syntactic rules for
drama
now story grammars they provide a
framework with which to expect certain
elements and sequences and to fill with
default values things are not explicitly
stated so basically a story grammar then
tells you that any story has to have
these things now if it is not if
something is not explicitly mentioned
here we fill it implicitly to make a
story let's look into what story
grammars is so this is basically a story
of the three little pigs now obviously
when I say a story of the three little
pigs
there are certain expectations that
people have what will this story have
right and so first of all there should
be character the bird organist and the
protagonist is there has to be first of
all if it is a story about three little
pigs so three little pigs have to be
there that is the main thing and then if
the three little pigs are there just
three little pigs going around is not
going to solve our problem so conflict
has to be made and a for a conflict and
a willingness to be an antihero has to
be put in and that is what the world
face so story dramas then give you this
idea that only the hero is not going to
make up a story so some kind of a
villain has to be brought in and P hero
is to brought in because int you know in
hero when they collide will produce the
kind of problems or the kind of
difficulties contradictions which has to
be resolved later on because no stories
work around this way and so I have now
created well now obviously if there is a
villain and there is a hero then there
is some kind of problem has to arise
because they don't cannot heroes and
villains cannot live together and so
what is the problem here the wolf wants
to eat the Three Little Pigs now we have
a story in condition so we have a
problem we have certain characters into
it we have all the characters into it
and we have a title of it so let's then
write the story certain events ain't
waiting so we can relate to what what I
had done is we have put in some so wind
blows the house will blows down the
straw house then will blow down the
steak house will
can't blow down the brick house will
climb the chimney and so these are the
three kind of houses these pigs have
they leave in and so once the wolf goes
ahead and blows it the the pigs create a
new kind of a house why they created a
new kind of us because they are afraid
of this particular wolf and they don't
want to be eaten and so this is the one
this is the is a set of events you can
create any kind of event just as the
look into it and then the resolution is
will falls into a pot of boiling water
and sort of or the open door and is
never seen again so the resolution isn't
the goal who is going to eat the things
so the resolution is these pigs were
actually boiling water and the world
comes down a chimney falls onto the
water burns himself and says that no one
not going to do this again lunch is
lesson and goes away and never returns
back again so this is our story is
created this is how situations is create
a certain contradictions of greatness on
and so forth
on this side you will see the Saudi
structure and recall and so I'll leave
it to you to actually read so basically
there are different kind of things in a
story for example what it is what is the
event structure of the event episode
beginning development simple reaction
and so on and so forth so basically then
most stories have these kind of filling
gaps and so this is how a story drama
really works and so what is the need for
a story grammar because it gives us
certain kind of insight of how our
story's going to work and then if
something is missing we can always go
ahead and fill that particular thing now
looking at something called gracious
maximum conversation up till now we have
looked at something called speech how it
is perceived what is Rama what isn't
misperception all those things but there
are certain makes in the conversation
there are certain rules of conversation
which needs to be followed and so
Gration gives these mixing so grace 1975
believed that for people for con to
converse
each must do more than just produce
utterances that that is phonological
sound they must syntactically and
semantically produced on which are
appropriate for example if you look into
two sentences I just heard that yo got
promoted today isn't that great if a is
saying and me says the Salt Lake City is
locate located in Utah and the third is
Charles Darwin is the
revolution they are not conversing at
all there is no conversation although
all the sentences here a semantically
correct syntactical e correct have
meaning but they are not following
conversation so there are certain rules
of conversation so what is it what is
the and again the a comes up with answer
then what is the square root of 34 BC is
that chocolate ice cream is sweet so
basically this is not how a conversation
is is actually progressing and so Bryce
described the speaker in a conversation
should actually produce some kind of a
maxim so follow some kind of a rules
into it the four Maxima are there first
is the quantity whenever we speak we
should speak in terms of quantity we
should not speak more we should not
speak less but we should speak enough
for example somebody asked you that time
and you say 4 o'clock this is not
quantity because what o'clock would be
morning 4 o'clock would be evening so
you should have given enough information
not too much information but enough
information then quality quality in the
sense that whatever you are saying
should have some kind of a context some
kind of a quality into it if there is no
quality that you have into your speech
if you have no context into your speech
or know the meaning into your speech
then it will not be processed in the
right way then you have maximum of a
maximum of relation if you are speaking
a sentence and two parts of the sentence
make no relation so I am going to the I
am going to the the market and Sun the
sun is shining on my head and the two
sentences have no relation with each
other so when you are saying two
sentences or when you're saying as
intense both the parts of the sentence
should have some relation and so this
maximum relation should be always
followed it should not be awarded you
should not be monster and also people
should have or speak sentences which
have relationships or which express
relationships into each other and for is
the maximum manner we should always have
good manners if you are speaking in the
wrong manner so if you are speaking to
somebody who's elder than you and you
say come here sit down that's not a
manners to purchase to be done
similarly speaking to people who are
smaller than you so certain kind make
sense or to be followed if it is some
somebody you senior to use
hold it please use words like please or
some kind of respect has to be given and
these are the Maxim's which is a
similarly if you are referring to people
who are below of your age of similar
ages okay but of below age then you will
have to use some kind of a mannerism
into it if you do not then you are not
moon to be a nice social person and so a
violation of rule a and B is there then
people are uncooperative and obnoxious
so just telling you something like
giving parts and bits of information or
no quality information no meaning
information at all then people are known
to be uncooperative and obnoxious and
people violating rule C are known to be
bizarre because if we don't say
relations if we just keep on saying
things then they are bizarre in nature
okay then
so what influences this language have an
other cognitive process up till now we
have seen what is the language and about
and how it is related to different
cognitive processes so what is the
influence that these language or the
language has on different cognitive
processes so there are two ways to look
into it first language and other
cognitive processes operate
independently one view see is that and
the second is language or other
cognitive processes are dependent on
each other and both of this view one
view says that they are separate
language has nothing to do with other
cognitive process and the other will say
that they are integrated together and
both of these are further explained by
two popular hypothesis of language in in
language cognition one of these
hypothesis is called the modularity
hypothesis and so what does hypothesis
actually say so it was proposed by John
federal ossified Jerry Fodor in 1982 85
I mean argued that some cognitive
process in particular perception and
language they are modular so they
process or they do processing in a
modular formula modality of a process so
what is modularity then modernity for
process says that it is domain-specific
operates specifically with certain kind
of inputs so language then is modular
because it operates only through certain
kind of inputs if you give the wrong
input language is not going to work
similarly with perception if you give
the wrong input
perception is not going to
taking place and some perception to take
place a certain kind of input has to be
given and the second is informationally
encapsulated which basically means that
operates independent of the believer and
other people's information available to
the processor so no matter what people
believe language is independent the
processing of language is independent
what we say is obviously independent
dependent on the context or what we
believe but the processing of language
if somebody says something to you how it
is processed that is in informational
informational its encapsulated which
means that language processors don't
depend on people's belief system or
their expectations to process things and
so this is how languages independent or
language is not dependent on the
cognitive process so basically then
modularity hypothesis or fordoes view is
that language is modular in nature and
that is why it is not related to any
other because it has specific in words
defined and formally specific inputs is
going to work and also the fact that it
processing is not dependent on people's
belief systems they are expectation
their views and so on and so in direct
opposition to this there is the woof
Aryan hypothesis referred by a by
example or woof Benjamin Whorf was
actually a chemical engineer and so he
gave the idea that language has to be
related with other different kind of
cognitive process which is out there and
so what did he say he said that language
and other cognitive process are strongly
related he believes that language
development has a lot to do with the
kind of atmosphere or the kind of
environment for somebody is born with
and so the environment in which you want
shapes your language right somebody
coming from a very rich environment will
have a different kind of language in
compare in comparison to people who are
coming from lower socioeconomic
backgrounds people who are coming from
those backgrounds where the language is
not English and so they're thinking
their language their whole idea would
change because the environment forces it
and so he believes that language as one
grows up learning and speaking organizes
and directs the way when perceives the
world organize information about the
wall around that happens because the
world around you gives you a different
nature of
the world interaction with you or your
interaction with the world gives you a
different kind of feeling a different
kind of thought process and this thought
process will then change the way
language is there and so when you see
somebody from the street the way he
speaks the way he is thought processes
and somebody from very a light
background when you speak is look at you
at his speech and the way he speaks both
are different and so this is the
interpretation of difference the
differences which is there so basically
then in this section on language what
with this does we continued from the
earlier section where we looked at what
is language and what are the parts of
the language and we proceeded by
explaining how language comprehension is
done or basically how long how speech is
produced so we looked at some water
speech production and how it is produced
and what are the errors can that can
arise in production of speech we also
looked at comprehension of text messages
and comprehension or sentences and
grammars we then looked at some
principles of better communication of
how people should be speaking and then
finally we looked at a very popular
debate the modularity versus the
non-modal arity or the debate between
the fact that language is like other
cognitive process and so it is
interacting with them against the debate
that language is different from other
cognitive process it should not be
interacting so this is the basic
overview that we did in language we
studied what is language how it is in
produced what are the rules for it and
so on and so forth later we saw it is
the production of language the errors
that happens with the production of
language the comprehension how
comprehension of spoken and written
language happens and then label the
errors that can arise there and then we
looked at how stories are perceived and
to end with we looked at a famous model
versus war Farion debater into a
language comprehension language
combination thank you
[Music]
you